signs is a very special film for me some
viewers may know it's the film that made
me who I am today
when it came out in 2002 I was only 14
years old and I remember my first visit
to see it very vividly it was the first
time I really started to think seriously
about film up until that point I hadn't
really thought about the art of
filmmaking
Sainz was the film that sparked the
desire that led to a purchase of a
camera many short films and a love of
movies that hasn't left me to this day I
firmly believe that if I hadn't seen
signs on that specific day I wouldn't be
talking to you guys right now strangely
the film deals with a very similar
message on coincidence and fate this
will be my fifth installment in my
series of analyzed movie reviews in the
past I've covered Prometheus Drive a
good day to die hard and only God
forgives signs is by far my most
requested so sit tight grab some popcorn
and let's reminisce to a time when the
name M night Shyamalan made people
shiver with excitement now and just
makes people shiver but I still love you
man never do that again though one of my
goals with this video is to debunk many
of the popular complaints that I
constantly hear about the film's finale
I will get into that later but just as a
warning
spoilers everywhere for signs so if you
haven't seen the film check it out and
then watch my review signs opens with
the main title sequence that brings back
memories of watching psycho for the
first time the loud score by James
Newton Howard was utilized in the
opening credits to hint at the intensity
that was to come in the film it was sort
of like a warning a promise that things
would get pretty freaky and the full arc
of the music isn't felt until the finale
of the film where that promise is kept
when the credits end our first shot
booms on the screen without much wait
and we see a pristine backyard one that
should emote feelings of comfort and
warmth but instantly we sense something
isn't right this is confirmed when
Graham Hesse played excellently by Mel
Gibson in my favorite performance of his
wakes up and immediately feels off from
this shot until the final moments in the
film an unwavering sense of dread
permeates this movie the thing about
this opening which Knight himself refers
to as his James Bond opening action
scene that impresses me so much is how
much you learn about Graham and just a
few shots you really get all the
essentials within a minute it's really
remarkable the photo on his end table
shows his wife and children as well as
himself in his priests uniform a faded
stain where a cross was once hung is
clearly seen on the wall as well within
a few shots a sharp eye can tell that
he's had faith and lost it when screams
from his crops send him and his brother
Meryl Joaquin Phoenix running into the
corn we meet Graham's children beau
played by Abigail Breslin in her first
role and Morgan played by Rory Culkin
our first lines from both of the
children are very important beau seems
to think she's still in a dream the fact
that she has odd possibly prophetic
dreams is constantly brought up in the
film Morgan thinks God made what lies
ahead of him it's clear now that Morgan
hasn't lost his faith this will bring up
a consistent struggle between himself
and his father throughout the film after
the Hesse family discovers the giant
crop circle in the field we now have our
movie can I just add that this is real
this isn't CGI I really really respect
that in the next scene we see that their
German Shepherd Houdini peed on the
floor the kids think he's sick and this
little exchange happens Danny peed look
he's sick
why don't you take him outside I'll call
dr. Crawford he doesn't change image I
don't know what to do
this is actually a really cool little
tidbit that I'll explain later
it's something I didn't notice about the
film for a long time soon we meet
Caroline a local police officer who's
arrived to hopefully give some answers
we soon learned that many animals around
the county have been acting odd the look
on Gibson's face always sends shivers
down my spine when she says other dogs
have been peeing on themselves like when
they smell a predator around it's also
during this scene that Graham asks
Caroline to please stop referring to him
as father we also get our first hint
that beau has a thing about her drinking
water and a pretty suspenseful scene
involving the family dog this scene also
includes some pretty good humour
something I think Knight really nailed
in this movie after a few moments of
silence Graham becomes unnerved by the
fact that he can't hear his children
anymore which leads to a scene my sister
couldn't even watch the doggy dies
Knight broke a rule of screenwriting
here never killed the dog kill as many
people as you want just never kill the
dog he breaks that rule twice in this
movie we learn of Morgan's asthma here
and discover that the relationship
between Graham and his brother Meryl is
a bit strained soon we cut to nighttime
the farm is quiet nothing is moving all
we hear is cricket's but suddenly they
stop chirping I didn't even notice this
the first time I saw it
but that subtle sound effects work
terrifies me it's like holy crap a
freaking alien just walked on the scene
and the crickets were like hell no bull
wakes up Bram saying there's a monster
outside her room Graham kindly tries to
put his daughter back to bed and we get
a really great scene where beau asks
Graham why he talks to mom when he's by
himself we sensed that she since passed
away this nice moment quickly ends when
Graham spots an alien on the frickin
roof
Shyamalan was clever in the ways he
chose to reveal the creature he doesn't
just show you it you get a little
glimpse which keeps you curious on the
DVD nights said that the killer coming
at you with a bloody knife isn't
necessarily scary but having the
knowledge that a killer is in your house
just not being able to see him
that's terrifying Hitchcock said
something similar and I'm paraphrasing
here a bomb going off is not suspenseful
that's the release a bomb underneath the
table and you don't know when it's going
to go off
now that's suspense so anyway Graham
wakes Marilyn they try to chase this
thing down outside still assuming it's
just some neighboring kids this scene is
pretty hilarious especially the dialogue
involving the fact that Graham doesn't
feel comfortable cursing soon enough the
brothers start to sense that this may
not be pesky kids
the next day caroline has returned
through conversation with Meryl we get
more hints at what happened to Graham's
wife and through a conversation with
Beau
we learned that she's really got a
problem with water she even leaves tons
of glasses all around the house
half-full and yes I think glasses are
half-full I'm an optimist Caroline
interviews Graham and Meryl about their
experience the previous night and
another scene that keeps the audience
chuckling but the subtle humor is always
quickly replaced with an air of dread or
worry as caroline brings up the fact
that Graham left the church and someone
might possibly have a grudge against
them soon both says that every station
is playing the same show and we see news
reports from all around the world
indicating that the crop circles are
happening everywhere one of the things I
love about this movie is that it truly
captures what it might feel like if a
group of hostile aliens attempted to
take over the planet some alien invasion
movies show worldwide destruction and
people from other lands running and
fleeing from big CGI ships to me despite
the fact that these movies actually show
worldwide invasion and devastation it
wasn't until signs that I legitimately
understood what it might feel like
because it's told from the perspective
of just this one family so it's vastly
easier to relate to as a viewer Graham
decides to take his family into town to
help get their minds off things and
through some comical scenes we learn
extremely important details about each
character Morgan is extremely interested
in this whole UFO thing and gets a book
about it bosz had a thing about her
drinking water her whole life people
still really feel the need to confess
their sins to Graham and then what is
perhaps the most important character
info
we learned that mayoral almost went pro
as a baseball player but wasn't able to
make it because it felt wrong not to
swing when they all meet up for pizza we
get another very important scene they
spot the director Shyamalan himself
accidentally walking into the frame oh
wait he's in the movie dang he gave
himself a big role he's the guy who
killed Graham's wife and started all the
characters on their fateful journey
towards Redemption yup the director the
guy who created these characters is also
the character in the movie who made the
first step that leads them all to the
finale interesting here's why it doesn't
bother me I saw this movie in theaters
in 2002 before I knew who Shyamalan was
because as I said this was the movie
that really made me want to analyze film
and learn more about them so I watched
his performance as if it was just
another actor and it didn't bother me in
fact I remember thinking this supporting
guy is pretty good so there are two cool
things I take away from this scene for
one everyone recognises him except Beau
who says who is he this is probably due
to how young she is she probably
wouldn't recognize him and when
Shyamalan drives off Graham is the only
one who starts eating taking a huge bite
trying to forget and move on this shows
just how tortured he is in the next
scene Beau's old baby monitor starts to
pick up signals from something but what
I always took away from this scene was
that the signal doesn't become clear
until the entire family is connected to
me this was a hint that the only way
they're all going to get out of this is
by working together that each member of
the family has something special also we
get the first hint of Merrill's future
obsession with the whole event the next
scene is honestly one of the most
suspenseful scenes I've ever seen in my
life
Graham decides to investigate his crops
at night the sound design for this scene
is perfect
the dog barking in the background the
crickets and the sounds coming from the
alien all lend to that warm feeling of
suspense I get from a well directed film
my favorite shot in this scene is the
angle below Gibson before he kneels down
the shot and Gibson's performance really
sell his desperation in that moment
they finally decide to turn on the TV
after Gibson's spots a freaking alien
leg and his crops and decides you know
what there may be something to this when
they watch the news they learn that
ships have been spotted around the
entire Earth I love that they're just
these little tiny dots on the screen and
not some overblown CGI creation it's so
much more realistic that way eventually
the kids fall asleep and we get what is
possibly the most important scene in the
entire movie Meryl is feeling very
worried and quietly begs Graham to be
like he used to be just for a little bit
Graham reluctantly tells him a story
about consequence coincidence and fate
breaking your average person down into
two groups those who believe things
happen for a reason and those who
believe in random chance the
conversation turns from light-hearted to
dark when Graham mentions the last words
his wife said before she died
he says she said see then swing away
Graham believes her brain was failing
her as she died letting random thoughts
escape her mouth without meaning
he admits he no longer believes in God
this is when we get our first dream
Graham is dreaming about the night his
wife died when he wakes he finds Meryl
has taken the TV in the closet saying
the kids were getting too obsessed he
thinks the aliens are using the crop
circles as a mapping system and talks
about how their ships might be cloaked
during the daytime due to a bird flying
into what appeared to be a wall in the
sky interestingly there was a deleted
scene in the film where the family drove
by a dead bird which would have linked
up in our minds when Meryl said this
next Graham observes his family falling
more and more into obsession and worried
night wisely plays a lot of this for
comedy rather than make it all too
serious when he gets a phone call from
who we eventually learned is Rea ready
sham Ellen's character we hear him say
father then what sounds like Claus
scampering on wood in the background the
phone goes dead and Graham looks into a
room revealing an incomplete dress still
hanging up the box in the corner has his
wife's name Colleen written on it it's
clear he knows he has just spoken to his
wife's accidental killer
Grahame decides to go to race house to
check on him but before this scene
starts beau tells Morgan she doesn't
want him to die who said I was going to
die he continues to repeat now earlier I
talked about the exchange Graham had
with his children the conversation about
taking Houdini to see dr. Crawford the
kid said he doesn't treat animals it
actually took me a few viewings to
realize something kind of cool Knight
put in the script that was very subtle
we get one wide shot of Ray's house
seeing that he is a veterinarian now
that earlier scene makes sense Graham
didn't want to take their dog to see the
actual vet since that's the guy
responsible for his wife's death I think
this is fantastic writing I love when a
director slash writer
respects the audience and doesn't spoon
feed them all the little details like
this next we get a very emotional scene
that is played with remarkable subtlety
on the part of Gibson and night honestly
isn't too bad here as I said earlier I
didn't know he was a director the first
time I saw this movie and the scene
worked for me the two men have a bit of
a recompense when ray acknowledges that
he's caused Graham to question his faith
he also mentions that he's heading for
the lake because some have theorized
that the aliens have been avoiding water
before driving off he tells Graham he
locked one of them in his pantry next we
get what for some myself included was
the scariest scene in the film most just
refer to it as the disturbing footage
scene this scene was actually listed
number 77 in Bravo's 100 scariest movie
moments it's the first time we get a
good look at the creatures but at the
same time it isn't the first time we see
the aliens is not in some beautiful wide
shot with sparks flying everywhere and
big CGI creations it's on a handheld cam
from a foreign country this is one of
the best ideas Knight has ever had
because it perfectly captured the terror
of what this situation would be like for
your average family I don't know my
favorite thing about this scene after we
watching it many times I noticed this
you can actually see the camouflage
creature crouching in the brush looking
to see if it's safe to come out
clearly it's distraught it's hiding why
is that this is very important it helps
debunk many complaints about the film's
finale which I will discuss soon in the
next scene Graham still doesn't want to
accept the reality of the situation and
tries to talk to whatever is in the
pantry in a brilliant use of tension he
uses the reflection of a large knife to
try and see underneath the door the
scare that happens in this scene is
seriously utter perfection
there is no loud boom or buildup of
music to warn us that something is
coming the hand just rushes out from
under the door its claws clicking
against the kitchen floor I'll never
forget showing this scene to a friend
back in 2003 after the DVD had already
come out he was sitting far forward in
his seat then he literally fell
backwards and hit the back of the couch
it was amazing after finally
acknowledging that some serious crap is
going on
Graham tries to convince his family to
head for water since it's a theory he
finds some merit in his family disagrees
however on the basis that they want to
stay where their mother raised them he
reluctantly agrees on the promise that
they board up every window and door in
the house I've also heard many
complaints about how the aliens are so
dumb that they can't get out of pantries
and threw wood beams I'll get to talking
about those at the end of this video
when the family is crowded in the closet
watching the news they learn that the
crop circles are indeed being used as a
mapping system Graham hears of people
flocking to churches around the world
and leaves the room Morgan tells uncle
Merrill that he wishes he was his dad
not Graham after the house is nearly
finished being boarded up the family
agrees to have what Graham is thinking
might be their last dinner
they each pick whatever they want but
when it comes time to eat Morgan wants
his dad to say a prayer this is a
reminder that Morgan hasn't lost his
faith something we learned in the
opening scene when he said he thought
God made the crop circles when Graham
refuses he breaks down crying and the
entire family comes together for one
last emotional scene just like during
the earlier car scene the signal from
the baby monitor becomes clear when the
entire family is grouped together
they rush to finish boarding up the
house when Graham looks out the window
the crickets stop chirping yet again
another warning that the creatures are
coming in the script night had
originally planned to show us lines
being formed in the crops as the
creatures advanced towards the house he
wisely omitted that visual I find it
much more terrifying without actually
seeing that thinking that this might be
one of the last times he has to really
talk with his children he decides to
tell each of them how they were born
interestingly the births described are
actually the stories of how nights
actual children were born all the while
you can hear the creatures crashing
through the house all tension throughout
this scene is caused with fantastic use
of silence combined with sound design
they head for the basement at this point
the creatures have gotten inside the
house and while trying to wedge the door
shut they knock out the lights forcing
them to use flashlights they notice that
the aliens are just making noises trying
to distract them from the real threat
they begin searching for the coal chute
remembering that it used to be poured
into the basement upon finding it an
alien grabs Morgan at night does
something really great here he focuses
on the fallen flashlight only letting us
hear Graham and Merrill screaming to
help Morgan it gives me goosebumps every
time Morgan begins having an asthma
attack causing Graham to realize they
forgot to take his medicine beau says
she dreamed this continuing to add
weight to her almost angelic prophetic
dreams as he's trying to help his son
breathe he begins talking to someone
else who we quickly realize is God it's
clear now that Graham really does still
believe in God he acknowledges his
existence but hates him nonetheless
eventually the asthma attack subsides
when the family is finally able to sleep
we get a little bit more of Graham's
dream learning the Colleen died in an
accidental car accident he wakes up
before the dream finishes when he wakes
we hear a voice on the radio a man who's
theorizing about why the aliens came to
earth he says people think they came
here to take over the planet that's bull
I don't think that
my friend and I saw them found a pack of
light bombs it poisonous family they
drag them away nobody believes me they
didn't come here for our planet this is
a raid that came here for us to harvest
us they left real fast this morning by
something scared him off they left
someone that wounded behind this little
bit of dialogue is very important as I
keep saying I'll get to that in a bit so
after a bit of reluctance the family
decides to go back upstairs in an
attempt to find Morgan's medicine when
Graham wheels the TV into the living
room we get a scare that made a woman in
the audience scream as if she'd
literally seen a ghost
I'll never forget that an alien is
holding Morgan and it's missing two
fingers it's the one from the pantry
clearly this is one of the wounded that
was left behind the family freezes as
they watch the alien threatened to
poison Morgan then Graham has an
epiphany and we finally see the rest of
Graham's flashback this is when Graham
begins to connect the dots and where
some audience members were let down he
remembers that Colleen's last words were
tell Graham to see and tell Meryl to
swing away he remembers his conversation
with Meryl about fate and coincidence
and has a revelation he's haunted by his
question is it possible there are no
coincidences
he tells Meryl almost pro baseball
player to swing away who begins to
attack the alien but not before it
poisons Morgan now we get the next big
reveal and more audience members got
turned off the water the water is
harmful to their skin
this was Bo's addition to the situation
Graham gets Morgan outside and gives him
his injection as Beau watches Merrill
trashed the alien exploding all the
glasses of water she left around the
house before too long the creature
breathes its last breath in the next
scene a very emotional Graham says
that's why he had asthma he keeps
telling himself that Morgan's lungs were
too close for the poison to get in as
his family waits to see if Morgan will
wake up
I think someone too in this moment
Graham regains his faith we pan back
through the window that was in the
opening shot and while that opening shot
was cold and filled with dread this one
is beautiful sunny and vibrant even
though the glass is smashed in a time
lapse occurs to the following winter and
Graham walks out of the rest room all
decked out in his priestly garb in the
film fades out now I have promised
throughout this review that I discussed
the film's ending and give my thoughts
on why a lot of the complaints I hear
are completely unwarranted complaint
number one the pantry I'm constantly
surprised by how many posts I've seen
complaining that the aliens can't get
out of a pantry or that boarded up doors
don't stop them and how idiotic that is
this I've never been able to understand
there's the alien from the damn pantry
he obviously got out how do you think
the aliens got into the house when the
family was in the basement they busted
in there is literally no reason to be
surprised by a living creature taking
some time to bust through something with
two tables stacked against it it's as
simple as this they don't have frickin
laser guns it's gonna take some time to
bust through something I mean this thing
even did it while I was missing two
fingers another thing people tend to be
like well how in the world did that
thing find them remember the crop
circles were used for navigation
obviously they live really close to Ray
ready because he drove right to his
house more than likely that thing headed
to the nearest crop circle trying to get
back to his race wasn't able to and went
to the nearest house complaint number
two the water this is the biggest one
water why would aliens come to a planet
composed of roughly 70% water there's
water in the air what if it rained I
have a large amount of theories about
this for one it's possible that these
creatures had never encountered water
before in their entire lifespan
I mean imagine that we discover a
faraway inhabited planet it's entirely
plausible to assume that there would be
unknown
on the surface that could possibly be
toxic to us perhaps something that our
technology isn't able to discover or
warn us about but remember what the guy
on the radio said they didn't come here
for our planet they came here for us
it's entirely possible these aliens have
absolutely zero interest in Earth they
only want to harvest us why does it
matter what else did we learn in that
radio scene that they retreated so fast
they left their wounded behind this
shows the creatures desperation this
shows they more than likely had no idea
what they were walking into and are
possibly a race in dire need of survival
looking for some last resort
remember the Brazilian video the
camouflaged creature cowering in the
bushes alone my guess is that thing is
terrified it's completely separated from
the group perhaps he's watched his
friends all die as they were exposed to
the atmosphere for an extended period of
time my point is this entire movie is
told from the perspective of one family
the information that the audience gets
is as limited as what they get
I'm sure if this was a film that was
directed like Independence Day which in
its own right is a really fun movie
showing countries all over the world
the suspense would have instantly ended
when they show a place that happens to
be raining now yes ray Reddy's character
said it seemed like they were avoiding
water but remember this you can't make a
crop circle in water which is what they
were using as a navigation system all of
this is subjective which is the whole
point it's about the terror and
confusion of one family trying to deal
with this situation which is why this
film is all the more affecting and
relatable lastly how long were the
aliens actually on earth okay so the
movie starts out with the family
discovering the crop circle then all the
crap starts to go down from that scene
to when the aliens leave the planet at
night only three days pass
I think people tend to miss this in the
course of three days the aliens arrive
on earth and likely send out a few
Scouts like the one we saw on the roof
then more are sent in a desperate
attempt to salvage anything they can
then they get the hell out of there as
fast as possible even leaving their
wounded behind this is why I'm always
surprised at the absurd amount of
complaints involving water it's very
obvious that this race of creatures is
immensely desperate and possibly even
scared scrounging for whatever they can
what makes this movie scary to me is
that it focused on one family and their
plight throughout this situation since
we know as little as they know it's
terrifying everything I just said really
isn't the point of this film however the
movie isn't about aliens or invasion
it's about faith losing it and regaining
it it's about a family figuring out how
to work again and I find that extremely
moving and since water is a universal
symbol of holiness and purification it
makes sense that night would choose that
as the thing that washes the evil away
signs is the reason I'm talking to you
guys about movies today I owe the film a
lot of things thanks so much guys for
watching this review I look forward to
doing more analyzed reviews in the
future I hope you enjoyed this and if
you like signs I hope you like it a
little bit more now and if there were
some things you were maybe confused
about I hope this may be cleared it up
for you and maybe just maybe if you were
annoyed by the water thing you're not as
annoyed by it now cuz trust me I
understand it's a little weird it's a
little different but the movie really
isn't about that also let me know in the
comments below other films you would
like me to analyze in this fashion guys
thanks so much for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck my nice